السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره قتلت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
شابين فلسطينيين في عمليه اقتحام ومواجهات
في الضفه الغربيه ففي بلده قباطيه بجنين
قتلت قوه اسرائيليه خاصه شابا فلسطينيا
اثناء اقتحامها بلده ما ادى لاندلاع
مواجهات
وفي مخيم قلنديا بالقدس عفوا بالقدس قتلت
قوته الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فلسطينيا ثالثا
خلال اقتحامها المخيم وقالت مراسلته
الجزيره انها عشره فلسطينيين اصيبوا خلال
عمليه التسلل قام بها جنود الاختلال في
البلده القديمه في نابلس
وقال الامين العام للامم المتحده عند
توسيع اسرائيل للمستوطنات وهدم هذه
المنازل وتنفيذها لعمليات الاخلاء يؤدي
الى اثاره الغضب والياس
قالت وزاره الدفاع البله روسيه اين لجنه
عسكريه روسيه بقياده قائد القوات البريه
زارت بيلاروسيا واضافت الوزيره ان لجنه
تتفقدت الوحدات العسكريه الروسيه ضمن
القوات الاقليميه المشتركه بما يدين
التدريب في بيلاروسيا قبل ايام من انطلاقه
روسيه بلا روسيه المشتركه
باسم قياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
قوته تعزز قدراتها الدفاعيه على الحدود مع
بيلاروسيا تحسبا لاي تطورات واضافها من
روسيا ان نشرت تجهيزات عسكريه تكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا تشكل تهديدا لبلاده
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بعيدا انه يتعامل
بجديه مع الوثائق السريه التي عثر عليها
في منزله وفي مكتب تابع له في واشنطن
واوضح بعيدا ان البيت الابيض سيتعاون مع
المراجعه التي تجريها وزاره العدل بشان
تلك الوثائق
من جاده قلى وزير العدل الامريكي انه وعين
مستشارا خاصا للتحقيق في اكتشافه وثائق
السريه في منزل الرئيس واضاف ان تحقيقه
سيتم مع اي شخص او كيان قد يكون انتهاك
القانون في هذه القضيه
بدوره قال رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي ان
على الكونجرس سبت اجراءات تحقيق بشان
العثور على وثائق السريه في مقرات للرئيس
جو فايدر واتهم الاداره الحاليه بالتعامل
مع القانون بمكيالين بحسب تعبيرهم التقى
مديره وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
ويليامبرز في العاصمه الليبيه رئيسها
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد الدبيبه
واتوقعت مصادر لجزيره ان يلتقي بيرنزر
لواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر في بن غازي وان
يبحث الطرفان العلاقات الثنائيه ووجود
قوات ضاجنا الروسيه في وسط وجنوب ليبيا
قال المبعوث الاميه الى ليبيا عبد الله
باتيلي ان المصالحه في ليبيا لن تكتمل الا
بحكومه موحده ونظام موحد بحسب تعبيره واكد
بت لان على الامم المتحده ان تدعم
المصالحه الوطنيه بوصفها مشروعا حاسما في
تامين السلام والاستقرار
اينما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير